des chinois qui se ruent dans les
supermarchés et un gouvernement qui
appelle à faire des stocks de nourriture
début novembre le ministère chinois du
commerce a demandé à ses citoyens de
stocker des produits de nécessité en cas
d'urgence mais sans préciser pourquoi
c'est une mesure assez mystérieuse qui
interroge la chine pourrait-elle être
menacés de pénurie alimentaire voire
pire de famine on y répond dans facture
[Musique]
c'est assez rare que le ministre du
commerce se fasse un tel appel on a eu
des scènes de gens qui sont précipités
pour faire des stocks quand le message
manque un peu de clarté se demande un
peu pourquoi et vous allez voir la
réponse n'est pas si évidente on a
d'abord demandé à notre correspondant en
asie quels avaient été les toutes
premières réactions d'un minois à cet
appel du gouvernement a constitué des
stocks est en réalité beaucoup se sont
d'abord inquiété du risque d'un
potentiel construit avec taïwan que la
chine refuse de reconnaître et que les
volontés indépendantistes inquiète
beaucoup
ces derniers jours il ya eu sur les
réseaux sociaux des rumeurs qui
circulaient certains ont vu dans ce les
appels l'imminence d'un conflit sur
taïwan puisque certains ont pensé qu'en
fait les autorités se préparaient à une
possible guerre que donc il demandé aux
populations de stocker des produits en
cas de conflit donc il a fallu que les
autorités viennent envoyé des messages
pour dire qu'ils n'avaient rien de
l'imminent sur sur taïwan alors même si
les autorités ont tout de suite réagi et
assuré qu'aucune guerre ne se préparer
avec l'île de taïwan comme toujours avec
la chine l'enjeu majeur est d'abord
politique
l'année qui s'ouvre est très sensible
pour le régime à un an seulement du
20ème congrès du parti communiste des
autorités qui sont très tendues qui ne
veulent pas se permettre le moindre faux
pas qui pourrait ternir l'image du
régime ternir l'image du leader parce
que si les choses se passent mal au
niveau social vient il y aura des
conséquences politiques
officiellement donc selon les autorités
constituées ces stocks était utile car
les récoltes avaient été
particulièrement mauvaise la raison
principale invoquée par les autorités
c'est un problème climatique la faute à
de fortes chaleurs couplé à de
nombreuses inondations qui ont ruiné les
cultures notamment dans la région
maraîchère de shandong dans le nord-est
du pays qui fournit énormément de
légumes résultat les prix ont bondi et
les concombres et les épinards sont même
devenus plus cher que la viande surtout
qu'il ne faut pas oublier qu'aujourd'hui
encore la chine reste le pays le plus
peuplé du monde et le régime chinois
c'est qu'il n'est pas autosuffisant sur
le plan agricole tu es un des gros défis
auxquels fait face quelqu'un ce n'est
pas nouveau c'est quelque chose sur
lequel ils travaillent depuis des
décennies on sait qu'ils ont fait des
investissements en chine et à l'étranger
sur des groupes agroalimentaires pour
pouvoir assurer renforcer ses finances
alimentaire n'est pas encore atteinte et
après ils ont aussi des moyens d'y faire
face d'abord parce que la chine avait
grosse capacité à lagny stocks
stratégiques prévus de longue date
et enfin et bien il ya ce qu vide car
même la chine n'en a pas fini avec
l'épidémie est depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire rachid a pris mantra je
dirais de faire une politique zéro que
vides ça veut dire que dès qu'il ya le
moindre cas boucle un quartier une ville
parfois avec des millions d'habitants et
des millions de chinois qui ne
travaillent pas ce sont aussi des stocks
qui diminuent même si le nombre de
quatre coronavirus reste relativement
bas en chine le gouvernement n'hésite
pas à parfois confiné des villes
entières ce qui peut bloquer des axes de
communication
le régime prépare une éventuelle risques
épidémiques dire qu'une reprise et
puniques forte qui ferait que le pays
devrait aller en confinement ou prépare
les gens à avoir des stocks est
d'ailleurs avec les jeux olympiques
d'hiver à pékin qui approche la chine ne
veut pas non plus prendre de risques
inutiles et puis surtout ce qui est
important de mentionner en ce moment en
chine ce qui inquiète ce n'est pas la
famine ou le prix du brocoli mais plutôt
le prix du charbon il ya la question de
la crise de l'électricité qui me semble
assez grave parce que là vous avez
refroidissement général de la
météorologie chinoise vous avez la pire
des crises énergétiques depuis des
décennies avec pénurie de charbon
plusieurs grands quartiers de grandes
villes chinoises ont été plongés dans le
noir les usines dans des endroits
extrêmement
productif on était plongé aussi dans le
noir évidemment ça ça a choqué beaucoup
d'habitants parce que ça crée une
inquiétude dans votre vie quotidienne
et ça a posé la question de savoir est
ce que il ya des problèmes
d'approvisionnement rappelons que la
chine dépend à 60% du charbon pour sa
production d'électricité est sans
électricité ce sont des milliers d'
usine qui tourne au ralenti et quand la
machine économique chinoise disjoncte
c'est bien toutes les chaînes mondiales
d'approvisionnement qui sont affectés
[Musique]